[Music]
all right rachel so i've been following
uh some news but not the kind you think
i like to follow sports news because you
know i'm known for my sports knowledge i
already talked about like inflation and
the
hard news no this is different these are
two of your favorite things sports and
money
this has been the hot artist go sports
this is from cbs news lebron james
nope i know
you ready for this lebron james is
officially
a billionaire really 37 years old okay
can i can we do a quick timeout just so
i can so all of us that are like me
listening can get our minds around this
that's not just from playing basketball
this isn't this is endorsements oh yeah
there's all kinds of deal sponsorships
you name it just
make sure not just his nba salary
eight-time nba all-star four-time nba
champ two-time olympic gold medalist hit
another milestone
doing something no other nba player has
ever done wow after another monster year
of earnings totaling 121.2 million
before taxes and agents fees over the
last 12 months forbes estimates he's
officially become a billionaire while
still playing hoops 37 year old
superstar is a net worth of 1 billion
and he said this is a quote from him
it's my biggest milestone obviously i
want to maximize my business and he's
done just that he's commanded more than
a 385 million dollar salary from the
cavaliers miami heat and lakers and uh
as the nba's highest paid active player
and off the court to your point rachel
he's raked in upwards of 900 million in
income from endorsements and other
business ventures so he's a very smart
businessman totally on top of being an
incredible jordan yes very similar
so here's the funny thing though this
isn't just why i wanted to talk about
this
yes he's a billionaire that's an amazing
milestone and that's a thousand millions
for those of you that need to get that
picture in your head
so
but my favorite thing about this story
is that he is known as the cheapest
player in the nba he's extremely frugal
i want to play a quick clip that our
team found to really illustrate the
point you ready i'm ready i can't wait
who is the cheapest guy in the nba who
is it and dwyane wade says
lebron james that is so
so so so false
that is so falsely true it is so falsely
true and using his phone if it ain't
wi-fi i'm not turning on data raw man
i'm not i'm not buying no apps i still
got pandora with commercials you know
you're rich right i'm not paying for it
i'm not paying
i love so that was lebron james himself
for those of you wondering talking about
how cheap he is and i love that he said
it's so so falsely true that's so true
he won't you i love that he needs wi-fi
he's not gonna go now let's be clear
lebron james is not living in a check
he's got nice house and i'm sure he's
got nice cars he's done really well but
it's amazing to me the things that he
goes i'm not paying three bucks for that
i'm not doing that i'm not paying for
that subscription pandora i'll have some
commercials yes hey do you know who else
is not a billionaire but listens to
pandora with commercials
rachel cruz me
that's me
we were sitting and i was like rachel
what are you doing playing pandora
there's an ad like do you not have
spotify who are you basically just i'm
basically like lebron that just means
you're on your way to becoming a baby
and no apps either no i love that no
like paying for apps yes yes i want to
make it clear lebron james is not a
cheapskate in fact he's very very
generous
and that's the there's a maybe a
connection there maybe you can speak to
this uh he this another article from cbs
news lebron says he'll open a
multi-million dollar medical facility in
his ohio hometown he's built the i
promise school in his hometown of ohio
he's sending 20 he's pledged to send 2
300
students to college debt-free through
scholarships amazing so to me i just go
this guy has a plan for his money he's
got a vision for where he wants it to go
and while he doesn't care about the
three dollar pandora subscription he's
spending his money where he wants to
spend it and i respect that absolutely
yeah because it's not the pandora thing
you know the pandora subscription is
going to make you a billionaire right
that's not that is not it but it's a
mindset too
of seeing like okay what's wasteful
what's not and it's that's the same
ways of looking at life
that really could lead you because i
mean that i mean that kind of stuff
could play into his business deals where
he's like um where are we what am i
doing right like it's that same thought
process that really can make you become
successful i mean it's wisdom it's just
wisdom with money and where where your
values lie lebron has to find wi-fi i
know i well here's the thing right now
can i be honest with you that's the one
that's funny i waited 20 years for space
jam 2 and i was so disappointed with how
it turned out
and that's partially lebron's fault but
i've gained newfound respect for him
after this whole yes this whole thing oh
man lebron so he wrote he ruined the
space jam franchise but he brought it
back you know what is so weird and i'm
not kidding i don't know if
what this is what's happening right now
but you know we do a movie night with
our kids on most friday nights from home
we do 90s movies so dunstan checks in
dennis the menace
uh blank check richie rich like we go
through all the 90s movies because we're
like because you've got to have you got
to watch these
uh jumanji was a little scary in the
trailer so we decided not to get
chimanji but do you literal do you know
what we're watching tonight space jam
yes the original the oh yeah oh yeah
yeah michael jordan michael jordan like
with looney like looney tunes one of my
favorite movies because my kids don't
know looney tunes like like bugs bunny
she's like millie was like oh is that
the guy that eats the carrot besides the
wb logo and i was like yeah because free
willy he's on for you know it's
hilarious so like all of this is
happening
train up a child in the way they should
go rachel there you go michael jordan
space jam so lebron
i'm happy for you i might pop by the
cruise house just to like be a part of
this moment eric can we keep going with
this topic or is this okay okay so
here's another 90s movie that i quoted
on the road when we had our building
wealth event there was a samsonite
suitcase and i made a comment about
samsonite haha you know i made a joke
about it george had no idea what i was
talking about he was like i don't get it
i was like well yeah from the from the
movie and he was like what movie i was
like dumb and dumber george said
never seen it and i said what i said
that is my husband's favorite movie fast
forward two weeks
ago uh winston and i haven't done i
don't know what's being talked about
he quotes dumb dumber as he does like
every week it's just like the the movie
quote always in our marriage and i said
do you know george has not seen dumb and
dumber winston said george campbell's
not seen dumb and dumber next thing i
know george campbell is driving to our
house when sarah's
rents or i don't know we actually use
your hbo max subscription that's right
and we say and we watch school we watch
george w george me and winston we
watched dumb and dumber it was a night
listen when you get a text from winston
cruz that's like hey come over tonight
we're watching dumb and dumber you can't
say no to that you clear your schedule
you move mountains
whitney was out of town we wanted to
come to clear so 90s movies yeah it's uh
it's an important thing that you need to
dive into so all you gen zeros out there
that i haven't seen those nine times to
be clear i'm not gen z i just had a
strange childhood i guess i guess so i
grew up arabic baptist we were watching
like veggie tales adventures in odyssey
we weren't allowed to watch that kind of
filth really you know at the ramsey
household that is one thing mom and dad
were not strict parents on they were
strict in some way you could watch we
could watch what literally would
everyone except for two movies can you
say them on air i can or two two things
rugrats we were never allowed to watch
okay
because the kids are in charge
that's what he would always say so david
didn't like that it portrayed in a world
hated that and then fern gully
hold on couldn't watch foreign is it
because of the climate change agenda i
don't know i'm not going to go down that
back that is hilarious
but dave's like it's capitalism they're
cutting it down to make paper rachel
it's how the world works get over it so
in the 90s we're on grads and fern golly
we were not but everything else forrest
gump ty anything
we watched y'all like
yeah and mom and dad didn't care this is
great content listen if you came here
you may not care about anything
financial advice and life change you
came to the wrong place sorry for the
segment i'm sorry there's no time to
move on the show's over rachel we can't
take a call quick oh no we can't take a
call quick hey but we can circle back if
you were a billionaire what were things
that you would you would still
who how would you be lebron how would
you i would still i would still coupon
and i know sharon ramsey kindred spirits
sharon ramsey because we both are big
fans of in being intentional is this the
best deal is there a deal to be had can
i use a coupon a promo code whatever it
is i'm doing it it's good regardless of
how much regardless of how much money
you have someone made fun of me because
of how frugal i was like george you
haven't paid for how why are you and i
was like you're never too rich to have
to get a great deal that's how i feel
that's a great line
i'm glad we're ending with that and i'm
not rich but i mean by american standard
sure by the world standards for my net
worth saying george you paid off your
house thank you rachel well listen we're
on our way to becoming billionaires with
our teaching already thanks lebron thank
you following in your footsteps good job
lebron we're proud of you man way to go
what a milestone as if we're friends
like he's gonna text me later